-Welcome back, everybody!
We are hanging out with BTS!
Yeah, come on!
[ Audience screaming ]
That's what I'm talking about.
Being in the biggest band
in the world
means there's lot of
information out there
about you on the internet,
but not all of it is true.
I'm going to read a few
BTS rumors I came across,
and you guys tell me
if they are true or not,
and what the story is
behind it, okay?
Does that sound okay?
Will you do it?
-Okay!
-Let's go!
Let's go!
-Here we go.
First, is it true that instead
of calling your fans Army,
you were originally
going to call them
"Bell?"
-That's true.
-Yes.
So it's kind of true,
'cause, you know,
when you say BTS,
it stands for
"Bangtan" in Korea,
not "behind the scene."
I mean, for your information.
It stands for "bangtan,"
and when you say
"bell" in Korean,
it sounds like "bang-wool,"
so it starts with
the same word, "bang."
So when we think of
the fan name,
somebody brings up
the idea, like,
what about the bell thing?
It was like, kind of like --
-Hi, bell!
-Everybody brings their bells
and like, "make some noise!"
And their bells, like
ring-a-ling-a-ling.
[ Imitating bells ]
But thank God that it has not.
Army's so much better, yeah.
-[ Laughing ]
Can you imagine, everyone
bringing bells to the concerts?
Ding-a-ling-a-ling-a-ling!
-Kind of cute, though.
-Yeah, it is cute.
Makes for a good Christmas song.
Jimin, when you guys
were deciding on stage names,
is it true that you
almost decided to go with
"Baby J?"
-Oh, yeah.
-What else was in the running?
-Yeah.
-Well, if you decide
to make it longer,
you can go with Jimin Fallon.
Jimin Fallon.
-Thank you, that's perfect.
That's the goal
of this whole thing.
All these years,
that's the goal.
-Hi, I'm Jimin Fallon!
-We're like brothers.
-Yeah.
-Why not? Why not?
-Alright, V.
V, is it is true
that you never actually
intended on auditioning
for BTS,
you just went to the audition
to support your friend?
-Swag.
-True.
Yes.
-What happened to your friend?
[ Laughing ]
-Only me.
-Only V!
-Okay, victory. Yeah.
-Yeah, oh, victory.
-Jin, is it true that you're the
best chef of the group?
What is your speciality dish?
-It's not fact.
[ Applause ]
-Ohh.
-That's what I'm talking about.
That's what I'm talking about.
Kimchi's my jam. I love it.
I love it, love it, love it.
Here we go.
Suga, is it true
that the first album you bought
was an Eminem CD?
-Oh.
-Ooh.
-And what did your parents
think of it?
[ Audience laughing ]
-J-Hope, I haven't
heard enough from you.
Haven't heard enough
from J-Hope.
Is it true that
you consider yourself
the most fashionable member
of BTS?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Listen to that!
Listen to the crowd!
-[ Imitating air horns ]
-Listen to the audience!
Let them speak for you!
That's what I'm talking about.
-Ohhh.
Absolutely! Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, I'm wearing
nice clothing
and short pants
and a slipper with socks, yeah.
[ Laughing ]
-Enough said. Enough said.
-Okay, okay.
-Finally, you guys have
been together for 8 years.
What's the most surprising
thing you've learned
about each other in that time?
-Oh, V sleeps
with his eyes open.
[ Audience groans ]
-Ohh.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-That's it?
-Yeah!
-I'm glad we
cleared all that up.
Thank you for doing that.
BTS, everybody!
Their CD single, "Butter,"
is out now.
Stick around, because later
BTS will be performing
their new song,
"Permission to Dance."
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody.